uh there was like [ __ ] a piece of wet
chicken
[Music]
hey i'm joe derosa and i'm here to
answer the internet what would you give
up first drinking watching sports or
coming watching sports how is this even
a question
sometimes drinking prevents coming ah
you know what i give up coming who needs
the
i've seen that episode of seinfeld where
george doesn't have sex they only
benefit from it yeah so i'm going with
that who's your favorite movie villain
darth vader
thousand percent number one villain of
all time
by mount rushmore of movie villains
darth vader the heath ledger joker
um tupac and juice
he's really scary at it isn't he isn't
it the [ __ ] razor blade
he's very scary in that movie
well let's say
uh joe pesci and almost everything
how much money would it take for you to
not drink for a year what is this i feel
that these questions are a little biased
how much money would it take i wouldn't
take much you know what i would not
drink you know what i would not drink
for a year for if i could make a deal
with the devil
that where he would say you could eat
whatever you want not gain any weight
okay at any time of the day whenever you
feel like it for a year if as long as
you don't drink i would do it for that
you want to ask me unrealistic questions
i'm going to throw unrealistic answers
at you would you be better at being the
pope or the potus um oh pope because
there's no accountability he's
infallible do you know that
i was raised catholic that's what
catholics believe is that the pope is
infallible so you could do whatever you
want and then just be like i'm in foul
but they're full of [ __ ] because when
the pope used to say gay marriage is
wrong they would all go pope's
infallible god listen to the pope now
the pope is saying stuff they don't like
they're going i don't know about this
pope
it's crazy
would you rather be filthy rich in 1900
or poor now
oh dude filthy rich in 1900 now dude you
ever watched a christmas carol no but
when he goes to the the to the nephew's
uh dinner at the end by the way i love
that he turns good and then just has all
the blood money poor now do you know how
bad poor sucks now because every schmuck
can walk down the street with the iphone
13 and you're looking at them going i
can't even have it i throw 13. people
are eating outside in front of you it's
horrible i wouldn't want to be poor now
it's been rubbing it in your face how
bad you [ __ ] up that you can't even
have the basic rich people amenities
that every poor person can afford 1900
rich
uh if you could bang any celebrity but
you'd have to make a sex tape with them
that would go viral would you do it yeah
i would make a sex tape with marissa
tomei enough people know my sex game at
this point they could talk about it if
they want videotape isn't going to
change anything
amy schumer uh once described a friend
telling her about having sex with me in
vogue magazine as a shoulderless worm
this is my friend by the way uh that was
like [ __ ] a piece of wet chicken
games out there
it's out there might as well have it out
there with marissa tomei if you had to
choose to die the same way as a
character from a tv show or movie how
would you die um damn dude well my
favorite movie is hannah and her sisters
nobody dies in that it's a woody allen
film my second favorite movie is glenn
garrett glenn ross nobody dies in that
my third favorite movie is goodfellas i
do not want to die like anybody dies
in that movie my fourth favorite movie
is empire strikes back nobody dies in
that
i'm terrified of dying so i don't you
know what yeah okay fine if i had to die
like a movie like like the way yoda dies
where you just disappear and then you
can just immediately appear again yeah
it's not [ __ ] dying
that's how i would die how much money
would it take for you to give up your
favorite food for the rest of your life
i have a few favorites uh the homemade
taco kit is way up my list i loved like
an old el paso taco i love doing those i
love kfc uh i love lobster i'm a man of
many tastes you give any one of those up
for life give me a million bucks i'll do
it what are we talking about here you
can substitute any food at any point
anyway i can't get the old el paso kid
i'll go get the the taco bell kit no
[ __ ] you
all right that means you're getting then
i'll go buy tostitos and make a nachos
and be like oh that hit the spot you
know i can't have kfc i'll get popeyes
whatever uh lobster
i was reading poor man's lobster recipes
today preparing for the future you can
make cod apparently you can make cod
taste like lobster are there sacred days
when you refuse to masturbate funerals
tragedies religious health yeah i mean i
would say 9 11. i didn't
the first one
wasn't in the mood that day yeah the
first of any bad day the day might be
yeah the day my nana died but not the
anniversary of
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore after the
first year
yeah that's pretty much it yeah
hope you enjoyed ati with joe derosa
please remember to subscribe like the
channel comment with other comedians or
celebrities you'd like to see do ati all
the good stuff